[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
distinguished guests please remain in
the East room please take your seats
and silence your cell phones the program
will begin momentarily
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
distinguished guests the 2023 NCAA
division one women's basketball national
champions LSU Tigers
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
of the United States and Dr Jill Biden
accompanied by the Vice President of the
United States and coach Kim Mulkey
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone go ahead and sit down
I'm so proud to welcome the 2023 NCAA
Champions the LSU Tigers to the White
House
thank you
in this room I see the absolute best of
the best
Jasmine Carson who led the team with 22
points going seven for seven in the
first half
[Applause]
broke the NCAA record for double doubles
in a season
Alexis Morris who led with nine assists
all of you
that one scoring the most points ever in
a women's title game
[Applause]
watching you was pure magic the way you
passed like you could read each other's
thoughts the air crackling with the
electricity of that
the crowd seemed to breathe with one
breath our hearts racing to the rhythm
of each thump of the ball
every basket was pure joy
and I kept thinking about how far
women's sports have come
I grew up before Title IX and young
women in my day just didn't have the
same opportunities to play sports I see
a lot of head shaking
over the years we've seen the push and
pull of progress including in women's
basketball
the attempts to create women's leagues
the 1996 Olympic team the WNBA and this
year went almost 10
will watch your final
shattering records
thank you
we've made so much progress and we still
have more work to do
your game was everything I love about
sports a team at the top of its game
refusing to let anything stand in your
way
as I watched I felt the history of that
moment of
before you who dared to be fast and
furious
who ignored the critics and just played
I thought about every little girl who
will come after how you showed them that
they belong on the court that they can
be strong and tough
that they can fail and fall down
take risks and run until their legs feel
like they will give out then run some
more
that they can win
you didn't just play basketball you
didn't just make history you showed us
girls and boys women and men what it
means to be a champion
you yes
you gave us hope and joy a way to find
that fire in ourselves
and most of all the chance to see you
soar
thank you for giving us those gifts and
congratulations once again to the LSU
Tigers
and now it's my pleasure to introduce
another incredible inspiring woman
amazing vice president Kamala Harris
well good afternoon everyone and good
afternoon to these extraordinary leaders
thank you Dr Biden for that introduction
and for your advocacy always I watch you
when the cameras are on and when they
are off and you are always fighting for
the equality of women in every sector in
sports in pay and Beyond thank you for
your leadership
and thank you of course to our President
Joe Biden to the second gentleman and to
all the distinguished guests who are
here and welcome to a group that defines
every way
truly excellence
coach Kim thank you for your
extraordinary leadership we had a moment
to talk about your seasons of winning in
terms of being a coach and inspiring the
young women of America thank you for the
work that you do
and to the winners of this year's NCAA
Women's Basketball Tournament the LSU
Tigers congratulations congratulations
congratulations
so a few months ago I had the chance to
meet Alexis and Angel and Floyd and I
was so impressed
by their Poise by their strength by
their intelligence and by their love for
each other
and I understood immediately when I
first met them how you all took home the
trophy because you are not just a team
you are a family you support each other
on and off the court
you represent your teammates your school
and your community with dignity and with
Grace
at every step
throughout your record-breaking season
you showed the world who you are you are
leaders you are role models and of
course you are champions
Tigers we know
through your grit determination and
Brilliance you changed the game
when you take the court you inspire so
many people across our country and as we
talked about earlier you are inspiring
people that you may never meet
but Through Your Excellence and your
enthusiasm you are lifting up whole
communities people around our country
and not only because of how you play but
because of who you each are
you remind all of us of what we can
achieve when we work hard and strive
with ambition
for all of us
from the youngest to the eldest
from the mouths of babes I congratulate
the Tigers and now it is my great
a leader who also knows a thing or two
about winning our president the United
of the United States Joe Biden
[Music]
thank you please
it's getting old hat for the coach
she's been here with 19 presidents
maybe your uh best moment in terms of
the team she's with folks uh thank camel
camel and Jill and uh and you just
described how inspiring this team is and
we
joined by many many fans all across the
country
and by the way it seems to me half the
folks in this room are from Louisiana
I want to welcome back president Tate
the last time we were in the white house
we talked about the leadership guiding
the university through the pandemic
this time we're celebrating the
Champions that have captivated the
nation with their talent and their heart
and their grit you know we're joined by
members of Louisiana delegation
Troy Carter Garrett Graves Mike Johnson
and a lot of alumni too we have proud
alumni Louisiana state here in my
cabinet
she'll stand up
[Applause]
class of 2004.
[Music]
okay all right
she brought she brought she's brought
Global uh global leaders together you
know how she does it she's up to the
United by the way she's a major major
player this Administration and I wonder
how's she getting all these folks up and
up in the uh you know the United Nations
she gives them she takes him to her
kitchen no no no no
to get to know each other she calls it a
gumbo diplomacy oh it's not not a joke
director management budget
Shalonda young where's shalanya there
you go Sean
putting together a deal hopefully
[Applause]
she's represent
Clinton Louisiana and is now helping
lead the critical budget talks for in
the middle of now but she said I'm not
I'm leaving the talks to be here
and we're all here to celebrate a
remarkable group of student athletes uh
you know
Angel Alexis Jasmine
4J you know the entire team you're it's
less than a year ago uh you'd uh you'd
never even played together
and Coach uh like I said uh your Hall of
Fame man let me tell you
it's uh I I and it's getting old for you
winning all this time
the Hall of Fame Championship coach had
a vision
nine new players joined into one pop
um it started the season five straight
100 point games
continued into the record 23 and zero
run
roll through the regular season with the
best in the nearly 20 years and under
the big
big final force ever
winning LSU's first national
championship basketball title
Angela Reese uh excuse me angel you name
the most outstanding player
wasn't any reason it didn't surprise me
and demand for tickets so high you you
caught you know you made it more
expensive for people to come
and of course the tickets went up 10
times 10 times and uh more than the
men's games
all right
the final was the most viewed game in
the history of women's basketball more
viewers than the NBA playoffs and folks
we witness history and here's what else
we saw parents and children who watched
every single one of your games together
sometimes driving 10 hours just to see a
play
and then and then we've seen you take
the time to talk to them to laugh with
them to show millions of our daughters
they can do anything as well anything
you know in this team we saw hope we saw
pride and we saw purpose it matters you
know it's been 51 years
guaranteeing all women and girls equal
rights to participate not only in sports
but in any school program today 58
percent this uh my colleagues don't like
and always mentioned this but 58 of all
college students are women
up from 42 percent not athletes in
college are women
sometimes more female athletes in
college and high school than there were
Millions more women are getting Sports
scholarships and a chance not just to
play but to earn degrees and build their
lives
but there's uh there's more progress to
make in the media 95 of sports stories
are still about men
it's not in this year though not with
this team
folks we need to support women's sports
not just during the championship runs
but the entire year and every season
showing up in person watching on
television creating more programming and
sponsoring and scholarships and
sponsorships and opportunities for
millions of women and girls to realize
their dreams and know they can do
literally anything at all
you know I just tell our daughters our
granddaughters they can do anything at
all anything any man can do
that's what makes America America is all
about possibilities that's what this
team is about incredible athletes
redefining what's possible and one more
thing we're hosting the Yukons men
basketball team later today and they're
the men's Champs
a lot of students
folks it's okay
we're getting
put some water
not to her but to uh any a lot of folks
standing up on this stage
folks uh the uh
I know uh
time to move on but uh the one thing I
understand I started to say later this
afternoon I'm going to be with the
Connecticut team the men's team
and uh
your cousin wants to have a one-on-one
don't put my money on you kid okay
you know that she got a she got a cousin
starts on another team I think what's
his name Hawkins something
with Jordan you think maybe yeah yeah
well we got we got we got a bet going in
our inside there so we there's a
basketball court down below
I think I'm joking so we're gonna work
something out here right yeah one-on-one
I have Angel yeah I got Angel too
and besides
experience are going to win
I tell you what between a brother and a
sister having two stars on championship
ball clubs the same year it ain't bad
but they're all around the Baltimore
area right
yeah that's my family all my family's
from Baltimore
as they say any rate
um thank you all again for your for your
patience for being here look
there's an awful lot an awful lot to be
proud of
and and the way in which women's sports
has come along is just incredible and
you and you're changing the name and
it's not just
suffered in every single thing
and it's really neat to see Sansa I've
got four granddaughters we had some
pretty good athletes I wasn't a bad
athlete my brothers weren't but all the
real athletes in this family are women
so uh yeah you got it you got it anyway
so thank you all for being here
there's over to you and uh and I again
want to congratulate you I assume
next year and next year
so uh
and by the way
that doesn't even count the new fashion
line she's going to come out with
no no you can use this if you want it
doesn't matter
if you can leave if you want anyone well
as as you can see we leave our Mark
where we go Samaya planned that no
samaya's fine for those of you who are
concerned Samaya is fine I'll assure you
of that she's kind of right now
embarrassed she doesn't want to leave
she wants
but uh she needs to be checked out I
would like to thank you
President Biden vice president Harris
I don't want to get emotional here but
we are a proud State I came back to the
state of Louisiana to be a positive
little did I know that I would get to
coach this group of people they came to
our state and you are looking at the
finest our state has to
we we have parents
never come where the parents were
allowed to come that touches my heart we
have my grandchildren my family we have
coaches families we have administrators
here as I said we're very very proud
I would like for Angel wreath I would
like for Emily Ward our co-captains to
present to you and your better half Dr
Jill Biden
creation
[Applause]
get in a picture
by the way one thing about Louisiana is
dangerous
you know why
our daughter was going to go to school
where her brothers went to school
she decided to go to Tulane
and I was worried and and see that guy
down there Landrieu the former mayor I
know a thing or two about his father
Moon I do too and his father moon is a
hell of a guy and took care of my
daughter because I was worried she's
come home with something away from bio
Lafourche or something you know
I was talking funny I couldn't
understand you know what I mean
language
none of us going to wash away and
besides it's an incredible incredible
state but anyway thank you thank you
thank you thank you we are honored
distinguished guests please remain in
the East room as the principals depart
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
terrible
foreign
[Music]
okay
thank you
foreign